leute was geht
als fresh
wir wollten ganz kurz hier mal die
gelegenheit nutzen also ich weiß jetzt
nicht
man sieht ja gar nicht meine augen auf
die andere seite
ich weiß jetzt nicht ob ich das
überhaupt wir das irgendwann hochladen
nur wir dachten und das ist vielleicht
hilft auf jeden fall erstmal für uns und
das ist auch vielleicht am einfachsten
ist weil dann haben wir das zumindest
und dann haben wir dieses video und
könnte natürlich sagen dass auftrat ist
jetzt einfach hoch dann sehen dass die
meisten und dann muss man auch nicht
mehr irgendwie auf install beim oder
keine ahnung dann braucht man sich nicht
mehr zurecht fährt genau ich dazu zu
äußern ja auf jeden fall haben wir uns
dazu entschieden
aus keinen schlechten gründen es hat
niemand was doofes gemacht oder
irgendwie was so was ist vorgefallen
dass wir jetzt nicht mehr zusammen sind
wir waren vier jahre zusammen über vier
jahre sogar was sehr sehr lange ist und
es war auch meine längste beziehung die
ich hatte und das war immer wunderschön
ja manchmal
ändern sich manchmal
manchmal passen die wege irgendwann
nicht mehr so zusammen wie man sich das
erhofft hat genau
und deswegen haben wir jetzt uns dazu
entschieden dass es besser ist erst
mal nicht mehr zusammen zu sein
und ja das wollen wir einfach mal gesagt
haben
damit teilt das alle wissen keine fragen
mehr aufkommen weil gut ich zum beispiel
ich hatte das schon mal dass ich damals
war das vielleicht auch noch krasser da
habe ich noch viel mehr youtube videos
gemacht und viel mehr leute haben das
verfolgt und dann war ich irgendwann
nicht mehr mit meiner damaligen freundin
zusammen auch im osten ist dass ich das
jetzt sage das ist ja eine rede aber ich
weiß dass das scheiße ist wenn dann
viele leute fragen und so man
nachrichten bekommt deswegen wäre es
halt cool wenn ihr das einfach so
hinnimmt
marie weiterhin supportet und
ja es weiterhin zu passen müsste gar
nicht
und also ich würde mich freuen und wir
haben uns alles cool und wir haben auch
weiterhin sag ich mal beruflich oder das
beruflich denn ich habe ja so eine
social media agentur da ist marie auch
drin nicht das waren auch noch irgendwie
miteinander zu tun hat aber das muss man
auch irgendwie lösen alles und ja ich
will mache ich auch nicht komplett aus
meinem leben verlieren weil ich weil sie
mir halt einfach wichtig ist und auch
immer gute ratschläge und alles gegeben
hat was hier auch alles gar nicht so
mitbekommen habt ja wir dachten wir
sagen das jetzt mal so wenn du noch was
sagen willst kannst das jetzt machen und
dann hoffe ich im
können dass alle verstehen
und nicht weitere gründe kann man
eigentlich es ist keine satire nur uns
was an oder es gibt nichts negatives ist
nur die gründe warum wir uns jetzt dazu
entschieden haben dass es so keinen sinn
mehr macht aber nur was zwischen uns
fallen man muss ja noch dazu sagen dass
es halt generell nicht so einfach war
eine fernbeziehung zu führen oder solche
dinge halt auch irgendwie da rein
spielen
und nicht so einfach sind
ja das ist das stimmt
naja
danke fürs zuschauen leute aber ich
alles gute und ja ich habe jetzt auch
wieder viel zeit für youtube dass ich
das gut durchziehen werde sowieso mache
ich glaube man sieht dass uns das extrem
schwerfällt und ich bin sowieso nicht so
der emotionale mensch aber das ist
wirklich sehr hart
[Musik]
haut rein leute ciao